marlon humphrey
raven's cornerback played every
defensive snap on sunday in the 28-24
loss to the steelers
tested positive based on a sample that
was collected before the game
the process of contact tracing and
identifying not just the closed contacts
but the high risk contacts that get sent
home for five days even if they never
test positive themselves right
that has resulted in a total of seven
ravens defensive players chris
being sent home for five days and the
way the math works they don't come back
till saturday right now they can play
sunday against the colts but this is the
las vegas raiders starting offensive
line conundrum where
you're not going to be able to get these
guys ready you got to do it all remotely
they're not going to be there for
practice now i think
and you tell me if i'm wrong i think it
affects defensive players less than it
affects offensive players agreed um but
uh but still you're not there to engage
in the practices that that will be
tailored to dealing with the
indianapolis cold's offense and so these
guys when they show up on saturday
they're going to be less prepared than
they would have been well yeah i mean
first off is there there you know some
pretty damn good names on that list too
where you go that's a good football
player i mean that's whoa matt judon
like what you know there's a few guys
through there i think we have the
graphic there it is patrick queen malik
harrison's and the other starting middle
linebacker i mean deshawn elliott's the
starting safety of course tyus bowser
plays a lot as outside linebacker so
those are all starters or major
contributors there
so that that hurts and to your point
mike like i would agree with you it's
worse for the offensive guys to miss
practice but still it's not that it's
that much better with the defensive guys
missing because you know to to what
you're saying hey the meetings the zooms
hey that'll be great they'll be able to
stay engaged and know what's going on
but it's about the test the coach puts
you through and practice and walk
through that really is what prepares you
for the game right hey we're in this
defense and when they motion the tight
end over here we want to make a check
and now switch to this defense right and
he's not going to get to go through the
mechanics of that like those type of
guys that's what i'm saying the outside
linebacker middle linebacker they're not
going to be able to you know hey check
check check hey we're going willy wonka
here willy wonka whatever i'm making
stuff up as you know but that is what
they'll miss those that dynamic too and
it's a good offense with the colts they
got a lot of different formations and
motions and a lot of different ways to
attack you and that might lead to maybe
baltimore i don't know being a hair more
vanilla on the defensive side of the
ball would be the one thing i would
think of because they are fairly
complicated and exotic that way you know
it would be great if there was a way to
actually simulate the presence of the
players at the walk-through and you've
seen those robots that have a an iphone
yeah right right you know it's it's for
something like this that is so random
you never know when you're gonna need it
you need seven of the robots yeah for
this week's practices to get the guys in
a position where they can be home and
they can see how it all unfolds around
them so this is just part of what you
have to deal with and as the look
without a home market bubble the nfl is
accepting guys are going to get it and
the reality is
cold and flu season numbers continue to
go up no matter how much some want to
ignore it the old plug your ears and say
la la la not listening
numbers going up
people are getting it in all walks of
life
and so when you send that 170 people
home
from every nfl facility every night the
chances are going up and up that
someone's going to get it and so when
someone slips through the cracks
provides a sample and is around the team
the entirety of game day on the
sidelines on the field in the locker
room wherever
you're going to have this procedure that
gets activated where the high-risk close
contacts get sent home even if they
never get it yeah which is going to keep
teams from being prepared for games and
maybe keep guys from playing in games i
mean if the ravens played thursday night
this week
these guys wouldn't play period that's
it and they're not going to move the
game for them that you know
they've they've
skewed away from a forfeit concept i
think in part because they recognize
they'd have to pay the players in the
event of a forfeit but their attitude is
hey look if you have a guy who gets it
and they have and you don't keep them
away from everyone else and they are
deemed close contacts you're just not
going to have those guys available next
man up and that's what the ravens are
going to have to deal with this weekend
chris yeah no it's it is it's the way of
the world that's why it's again it's
going to be more important
you know now than ever
for the players to really be
you know
on on their game as far as when they
leave the facility
yeah we're getting towards the holidays
and
college kids are coming back and people
are gonna start traveling and they're
not going to
you know sequester themselves inside of
a room for 14 days that's just not going
to happen across it's it's just the fact
of the matter so you know i do it's it's
on these players especially men if
you're on one of these teams these
winning teams super bowl type teams
fighting for a playoff spot wow i know
me as a next player i would be
like
my own bubble boy i really would be you
know oh honey they're coming here no
they're not i got a game this sunday
sorry stay away
well i'm not even sure i'd let my kids
in school in a year like this if i was
the quarterback of a football team i'm
dead serious i'd be like kids sorry you
know dad's making 28 million playing
quarterback you got to sit home and do
it on zoom i don't know what else there
is to say but i i uh it's it's still
going to be a tough fight here as like
you said the flu season picks up you
know this is stuff that isn't getting
discussed in part because the media
access isn't what it has been ever
before because it's all reliant upon
these periodic zoom conferences and you
don't get a whole lot of questions in
thanks there are there are coaches who
are staying in hotels and not at home
yes because they have kids in school
right they're trying to avoid it so
that's part of the reality and and look
i i think this is a point where we just
pause for a second and say the
pittsburgh steelers one of the reasons
why they're 7-0 and one of the reasons
why they're going to continue to be
great this year i think they've got it
top to bottom the organization they've
got the message
communicated to every player right and
and you know shereen and i were talking
about this yesterday
one of the benefits of being afraid of
your coach
is you do never not want to ever piss
him off and i think mike tomlin combined
with that veteran leadership and that
laser focus they're not going to put
themselves in a bad spot no we heard
anthony lynn say it back during hard
knocks when he was talking to his
chargers players whoever masters this is
going to be in position to win the super
bowl and here are the steelers they the
only the only whiff of an issue they
have is the fact that they played the
ravens on sunday and their guys were
around marlon humphrey although the nfl
continues to believe that's not nearly
enough to transmit the virus from one
player to another
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports